>> Dan: WELCOME BACK TO THE
"HANNITY" SPECIAL.
"THE 2020 ELECTION."
THIS WEEK'S DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE RADICAL
DEMOCRATS UNLEASHED ON THE HOT
BUTTON ISSUE ON ABORTION.
WATCH THIS.
>> LET'S ALSO NOT FORGET
SOMEONE IN THE TRANS
COMMUNITY, TRANS-FEMALE, POOR
BUT DOESN'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
EXERCISE THAT RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
SO I ABSOLUTELY WOULD COVER
THE RIGHT TO HAVE AN ABORTION.
>> I WOULD MAKE CERTAIN THAT
EVERY WOMAN HAS ACCESS TO THE
FULL RANGE OF REPRODUCTIVE
SERVICES INCLUDING BIRTH
CONTROL, INCLUDES ABORTION AND
IT INCLUDES EVERYTHING FOR A
WOMAN.
>> FIRST OF ALL, LET ME TELL
YOU THIS.
IT DIDN'T COME UP YET BUT
LET'S SAY THIS.
MEDICARE FOR ALL GUARANTEES
EVERY WOMAN IN THIS COUNTRY
THE RIGHT TO HAVE AN ABORTION
IF SHE WANTS IT.
>> Dan: HOLLYWOOD LIBERALS
PROP UP THE DEMOCRATS POLICY.
JON VOIGHT RESPONDED TO A
TWITTER ATTACK FROM RADICAL
ACTRESS ALICEIA
ACTRESS ALYCEIA
ACTRESS ALYSSIA
ACTRESS ALYSSAA
ACTRESS ALYSSA MILANO.
>> COME AFTER ME.
I'M READY.
>> DARLING, ALYSSA, GOD BLESS
YOU.
I PRAY GOD SENDS HIS LIGHT OF
TRUTH ON ALL OF THOSE WITH NO
TRUTH ABOUT THE REPUBLICANS
AND ABOUT OUR PRESIDENT.
MAY GOD BLESS AMERICA.
>> JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION IS THE TRUMP 2020
CAMPAIGN NATIONAL PRESS
SECRETARY KAYLEIGH McENANY
AND THE "DAILY CALLER"
REPORTER KERRY PICKET.
ALYSSA MILANO CRITICIZING JON
VOIGHT.
SHE WAS IN "BEVERLY HILLS
CHIHUAHUA 2" AND HE WON AN
ACADEMY AWARD.
DOES HOLLYWOOD EVEN MATTER
ANYMORE?
IT DIDN'T HELP HILLARY IN THE
2016 ELECTION.
>> NO.
HOLLYWOOD DOESN'T MATTER.
IN FACT, IF ANYTHING IT'S A
CURSE FOR A CANDIDATE BECAUSE
EVERYDAY HARDWORKING MEN AND
WOMEN LOOK AND SAY AALIYAH
MILANO -- ALYSSA MILANO IS
GOING TO TELL ME WHAT TO DO?
SHE SAID TO HAVE A SEX STRIKE
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO KEEP A
LIVING BABY WITH A HEARTBEAT
ALIVE.
WOMEN EVERY SHOULD HAVE A SEX
STRIKE.
WOMEN EVERYDAY WOMEN, TUNE HER
OUT.
SHE DOESN'T MATTER.
NOR DOES HOLLYWOOD.
THEY ARE A JOKE.
PLEASE ENDORSE THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE.
>> WHO IS GIVING THE DEMOCRATS
THE AWFUL ADVICE THAT ABORTION
TO THE NINTH MONTH OF
PREGNANCY IS A WINNER OUTSIDE
OF CERTAIN ENCLAVES IN NEW
YORK, CALIFORNIA AND ILLINOIS?
IT'S ABSURD.
WHAT HAPPENED TO SAFE, LEGAL
AND RARE?
IT SEEMED TO HAVE GONE OUT THE
WINDOW.
>> THAT IS SO TRUE.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
RIGHT AFTER RALPH NORTHAM
GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA MADE
ABSURD COMMENTS ABOUT THE
POST-BIRTH ABORTIONS DEMOCRATS
BEGAN TO GET SCARED.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IT AND THEY EXPLICITLY STEERED
AWAY FROM IT IN THE DEBATES.
HOWEVER, IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT
A LITTLE CRAZY DIDN'T COME
OUT, PARTICULARLY OUT OF
JULIAN CASTRO ABOUT THE TRANS
COMMUNITY HAVING ABORTIONS.
THEY ARE CALLING IT
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE NOW.
BUT NOW THEY WANT TO REPEAL
THE HYDE AMENDMENT THAT MEANS
THE FEDERAL TAXPAYERS DOLLARS
WOULD GO TOWARD ABORTIONS.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY VILIFY ALL THE STATES
THAT PASS THE HEARTBEAT BILLS.
SO STILL, YOU HAVE A NUMBER OF
DEMOCRATS WHO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY DON'T MAKE THE SAME
MISTAKE THAT HILLARY CLINTON
MADE IN 2016 WHEN SHE SAID HE
IS WOULD SUPPORT ABORTION
THROUGH THE THIRD TRIMESTER.
>> Dan: CANNOT PLAY WELL IN
THE SWING STATES HERE.
YOU LOOK AT THE ONE ISSUE
VOTERS, PEOPLE WHO VOTE ON ONE
ISSUE.
FIREARMS, SECOND AMENDMENT AND
ABORTION.
THIS WON'T LOOK GOOD FOR
DEMOCRATS WHEN THE PRIMARY IS
OVER, RADICALISM ON ABORTION.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
THIS MOTIVATES THE REPUBLICAN
BASE IMMENSELY AND IT
MOTIVATES 85% OF AMERICANS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHO SUPPORTS
ABORTION PASSED IN NEW YORK
AND CELEBRATED WITH A STANDING
OVATION IN THE CHAMBER AND
THEY LIT ONE WORLD TRADE PINK
AND IF YOU LOOK WHO SUPPORTS
THIS INSANE MEASURE TO KILL A
FULLY VIABLE BABY IT'S ABOUT
15% OR LESS.
SO THEY ARE MOTIVATING 85% OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHEN THEY
DO THINGS LIKE 19 TIMES
BLOCKING A VOTE IN THE HOUSE
FOR A KEEP-ALIVE BILL, KEEPING
A BABY ALIVE OUTSIDE THE WOMB.
PURPORTEDLY THEY AGREE WITH
THE GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA YOU
CAN SUPPORT INFANTICIDE.
THIS IS SICK.
THEY ARE BECOMING 1% THAT UP
SUPPORTERS INFANTICIDE.
>> Dan: IT'S ONE THING TO
ARGUE FOR CHOICE.
IT'S NOT CHOICE.
IT'S NOT A CHOICE FOR INFANT
IN THE WOMB.
BUT SOMETHING ELSE FOR
ABORTION.
CAN THEY TURN BACK FROM THE
PRIMARY AND TURN AROUND IN THE
GENERAL?
>> NO WAY.
THINK ABOUT IT.
THE WHOLE IDEA OF ARGUING THE
THIRD TRIMESTER ABORTION ON
THE NATIONAL STAGE, THE
DETAILS OF GOING INTO THAT, I
DON'T SEE IT.
FRANKLY I ONLY SEE DEMOCRATS